بعد ساعات من اطلاقها للبومها الجديد
الالبوم الذهبي اشتعلت مواقع التواصل
اجتماعي بالحديث عن ورطه وقعت بها المطربه
اللبنانيه كارلوس معها الالبوم الذي تغني
فيه كارول اثنتي عشره قصيده للشاعر
الفلسطينيه الشهير الراحل محمود درويش
يبدو ان صناعه ان صناعه سقطوا عفوا في
جزئيات تحرير كلمات الخاصه بقصيده ستنتهي
الحرب فضلا عن مساله حقوق الملكيه الفكريه
فمؤسسه محمود درويش القائمه على ملكيه
حقوق الفنان الفكريه استنكرت استخدام
قصائد شاعر الكبير في اغنيات سماحه وطالبه
بحذف اسمه واتخاذ اجراءات فوريه مراعاه
لحقوق الملكيه الفكريه المؤسسه قالت في
بيان الله ان الكلمات المنسوبه لمحمود
درويش في اغنيه ستنتهي الحرب ليست من
اشعاره وانما من انتاج مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مؤكده انها ليست بمستوى الشاعر
المعروف يعني على فكره كتير مرات صارت
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مشكله في بعض
الاحيان
في القراءه تكتبين لي مرحبا اقراها احبك
الخاطره هي صارت تنزل على صفحات التواصل
بمواقع على انها لمحمود درويش وقيسوا على
ذلك كتير فعلا